parents of the 30 year old man killed in
a motorcycle crash flew into town to
bring their son's remains back home this
crash happened just after midnight
yesterday on southbound 95 right by ann
road shutting down the freeway for
several hours victoria saha spoke with
the family and has more tonight
mom kimberly davis holds on to the lost
belongings touched by her sons
30-year-old aaron barris too emotional
to show her face he rode every chance he
got he loved to ride nevada state police
say barris was riding on the on ramp of
u.s 95 at a high rate of speed when his
2020 suzuki motorcycle wheel locked
causing it to skid and hit the median
barrier wall
barris was thrown off and hit a light
pole
he looked for that bike for a long time
and he just got it
about six or eight months ago this is
video bearers posted on his facebook
page a few months ago his mom said he
had just finished his shift working
security at the wind just after midnight
tuesday when the crash happened barris
was an army veteran and worked at his
local sheriff's department in florida
recently moving to vegas to be closer to
his son colt he loved his son more than
anything
he loved his family
he would do anything for anybody dave is
recalling her last conversation with her
son monday afternoon he saw something at
the store that made me laugh and he
facetimed me and showed me and
just like love you mom talk to you
tomorrow victoria saha live local now
the family has set up a gofundme to help
with building a trust fund for bruce's
son you can find that link over on our
website at 8newsnow.com